[Musique]
bon appétit
voyez un le gigola est en train de
tourner tranquillement à la broche et
très très bien pas à la fête 30e bon
jour mais bien sûr regardé je délègue de
drogue sur delahaye au prince est
essentielle saint gilles gosselin est
une journée sans soleil ça fait c'est
pas moi c'est ça suffit ça se piquent
oui c'est vraiment stationnement eh bien
allez allez regarder une cuillerée de
suisse qu'en fait c'est vrai de sucre 3
cuillerées de sucre assez clafoutis une
clope outil on va faire une source il
est bon on va mettre j'épluche et petits
pois les pentes c'est mieux je n'ai pas
honte de catherine je n'ai pas pu y
mettre un jaune d'oeuf
voilà un journée la sortie faisait plus
chaud des petits pois pendant que les
garçons francs le kg la routine un bon
alors ici je vais mélanger les jaunes
d'oeufs avec le sucre tiré dessus trois
jeunes des non non non je me tais jona
d'oeuvre un seul héros là haut pour 4
personnes environ dont ce gamin déjeuner
alors à faire plusieurs alors maintenant
que j'ai mélangé voyez-vous le jaunes
avec le sucre
je vais ajouter un oeuf entier je crois
qu'il faut bien mélanger bien mélanger à
la femme pieds deuxième opération on a
pâti alors que mais l'enjeu cet oeuf
entier avec le truc encore il va lutter
la farine les quantités de farine la
quantité de farine permettent aux trois
autres comédiens comportera 2 1 jaune
d'oeuf et infantile john deere et un
apatride cuillère en bois pour mélanger
voyez-vous beau mélange voilà alors je
passe à l'opération aux farines lorelei
à deux cuillères deux trois fois parce
qu'il a eu avec une clio était
débordante est comme ça et je suis
absorber voilà vous savez pour l'instant
ces 161 chevaux quelqu'un fait qu'ils
sachent à régis gants et quelques
boutons quoi ça c'est un petit peu la
vie à quelques gouttes de pluie ont fait
fort désagréables ou de pluie alors
maintenant je mets un morceau de beurre
dans la poêle au la bataille du nom sous
terre au nom d'une grosse noix legault
se noient pas une noix de coco voilà je
mets là je viens d'être le moteur alors
je connaître la du lait ou de la crème
selon mon goût en l'occurrence je vais
mettre 3 cuillerée de crème toujours
pareil
une aide pour le crémant se monte à
lorient 3 plusieurs croient que voilà et
puis je pense que certains petits pop
corn et on la chaleur marseille m'a pris
mais vous avez récupéré votre matériel
un marché bien mais lloris
bon eh bien maintenant ça y est on passé
vers celle versée
[Applaudissements]
comment ne peut pas voir la flamme comme
on ne peut pas voir la flamme je suis
obligé d'envoyer la main pour qui c'est
vrai ça je ne peux pas le croire alors
j'arrose un tout petit peu le gigot pour
pas la rose est trop souvent il faut
l'arroser tout de même un quart d'heure
en gros en gros c'est vrai un quart
d'heure par livre en gros c'est vrai
alors ici au fond c'est une grosse crêpe
de soie footy devant vous savez les
clafoutis un général se font avec des
cerises
vous savez ce que c'est c'est un plat
spécifiquement tôt dernière le club
d'outils oui les foi se sont alors comme
je n'avais pas de cerises mais cerisiers
sont pas encore mûrs mais mes
framboisiers leçons alors je me suis
alors je vais force mais ici comme ceux
ci le framboise largement bien sûr de
quoi s'offrir à moi j'aime beaucoup de
temps passez vous avez enlevé les petits
les petits pépins
tu peux pain le peuple dans le framboise
mme wallon lund qui les grains oui non
vous voulez dire allez là que
d'apprendre oise qui est toujours un
petit peu attachés oui je vois la voyons
là
ça y est et bien maintenant j'aime avait
quand même un mouvement de rotation
comme ça arc
tout à fait mais effectivement ça pour
ça y ressemble beaucoup
vous aviez préféré n'émettre champignons
mais dans ce moule est aux framboises et
ola selecta sur elle même et je voulais
c'est un souhait très doué à nager
maximum elle sur maxime catherine je
suis sûr maximum parce que justement je
devrais il faudrait mieux vous avez
raison d'ailleurs je devrais mettre sur
feu doux mais là je ne vais pas la
sécurité ayant peu de vent alors faut
être sûr que tout marche bien je laisse
quant à la jeunesse cuir voyez vous
laissez cuire exactement comme une
grosse crêpe
car en fait qu'est ce que c'est quand la
faute si je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure
et je vais me répéter mais je crois que
là on pourra le répéter éternellement
c'est une pâte à crêpes dans laquelle on
fait cuire à la poêle des cerises noires
à de préférence et non les pépines série
et non en volant les pépines et non non
il nous est noyauté non dénoyautées
d'entre nous est alors oui seulement
évident effectivement ça c'est le
classique que le vrai classique
c'est comme ça que en auvergne parce que
je crois je crois que la cuisine je vais
faire je vais donner un petit un petit
remerciement à delteil qui a écrit la
cuisine paléolithique
en effet c'est de la cuisine
paléolithique c'est de la cuisine tels
que l'on peut imaginer dans la plus
grande de toutes les simplicité comment
on pouvait faire à l'aube des temps des
choses d'une grande simplicité avec quoi
avec des jeux parce qu'on pouvait avoir
des oeufs du lait parce qu'on pouvait
effectivement avoir du lait et des
cerises parce qu'on pouvait les cueillir
il n'ya il n'y a pas de transformation
n'ya pas il n'ya eu il n'y a eu aucune
transformation ne remettez pas de
mayonnaise en tube voilà c'est ça alors
là la mayonnaise en tube ce n'est pas
pas au lit paléolithique du tout ni
néolithique d'ailleurs la cce au
contraire ultramoderne à l'envoyer ou
ici je m'en vais pouvoir la faire sauter
complètement la faire sauter entièrement
on a regardé pas hein parce que vous
avez alors là c'est là la caméra qui va
avoir du mal à suivre
parce que c'est un mouvement
un peu brutal en fait je suis obligé de
l'opérer brutalement ça je ne réussirais
pas je suis inquiète pour une fois ils
arrivent à l'heure on est tanné voilà
elle va vous voyez vous allez tomber un
petit peu au le tandem qui peut faire
tomber un petit peu enfin c'est pas
énorme non c'est pas énorme
elle est aussi le plus beau le plus
incroyable qui sont en voyage d'affairé
alors voyons maintenant alors là il n'y
a plus de problème elle est absolument
puis comment gérer cela au sérieux parce
que le fruit le fruit qui est à
l'intérieur n'a pas besoin absolument
cuit et pas il peut rester
ce qui est important c'est que la crème
soit cuite est le fruit peut rester cru
et c'était le cas d'ailleurs des cerises
des cerises ne sont pas entièrement cuit
non mais là les trois s'embrasser devant
parce que réellement il ya dix ans n'ont
pas pas de drame parce que diana pas
mais est ce vraiment voulu montrer que
c'est un drame car nos jeunes amis je
suis bien sûr qu'il leur arrive à de
faire bien pire que ce soit d'entrée non
non non je le laisse moi je croyais je
ne voyais ça je sais faire oui oui oui
alors maintenant je voulais me donner
une assiette du voile a glissé sur une
assiette et puis voilà je crois que ça y
est nous allons nous allons terminer
alors le gigot qui sera suivie n'est ce
pas ensuite de voyez-vous delà du
clafoutis une petite salade et puis je
crois que ce sera comme ça très bien
alors bon appétit à nouveau répéter avec
les petits pois qui seront qui tout
allait
[Musique]